you want to say your name Dean Ronald
director I'll just go with that for now
trying to narrow it down no no I am
going to Africa on Monday okay that's
what we want to ask you about so tell us
yeah a buddy of Mines directing he's
been he comes from a short world he's
only done shorts and he's very very
talented and we've always kind of wanted
to you know produce him funny enough he
called us and said hey you know I have
this this actor who was producing and he
you know when he's acting he really
needs other producers and it was kind of
work backwards director of getting
producers you know but we go on him for
years and I think he you know felt
comfortable with us coming on to make
sure the movie gets made so so yeah long
story short three-quarters of its in
Africa Tanzania
you'll be there I'll be there three
weeks the directors already been there
for about six weeks and the production
is about live but I got to get back
because I probably going to India after
so yeah wait my glasses oh my god
tonight you know what that is the power
of Polish shorts right between projects
like what are you gonna keep yourself
motivated you know it seems like we
always have a feature or something that
we're either producing or riding
director we've been really fortunate
even though it's you know been
low-budget films it's been keeping us
busy you know for years I think just
trying to continue to take what we've
done to get to know more people based
off of that that's allowed us to keep
keep it flowing you know keep it keep it
going for now and you know it's
partnering up not being afraid to
partner up and not being afraid to leave
the country to find money courage how
are you this guy's younger brother I'm
gonna caught on hold down the fort here
we've been busy in India so rebuilding
these India relationships and we'll be
making the movie at the same time it's
actually we are making relation with
Bollywood I was in Mumbai for about like
three weeks and me going back the end of
September exactly right now where we're
making going bongo directed by Gregory
the map do tell already
no I didn't get the details oh okay
what do you do to keep yourself pumped
up between projects which I what do you
do to keep yourself pumped up between
projects so much I play Mortal Kombat on
the ps3 like worldwide no I know I'm
kidding no you know what I do I do I
invest a lot of time in the family I
have two sons but I write and I produce
and I help out with other projects that
are going on and any way I can lend a
hand so what's the best way to get out
of a funk when you're waiting for the
boundaries what's the best way to what
you don't wait for the phone to ring you
pick up a camera and you do it yourself
so pick up a pencil you do it you're
right you bug your friends to cast you
know if you if you stay not moving and
you're standing still there's not it's
so uh it's so profound isn't it no but
it's true you know it's easy to get
depressed and be like oh poor me
nothing's ever gonna happen but no you
have to if you're if it's not happening
for you you got to create yourself
that's kinda why we got behind the
cameras early on
in college or whatever it's because we
did not want to wait for the phone to
ring did not want away so we have to
take take take it by the nobody struts
steer yeah you talk all day about making
stuff but it's a you know taking action
you know there's a filmmaker I know name
David Brent and we took action really
animated film and called goodbye promise
and I mean which we go started and we're
really excited to be part of that as
well which gets released next Monday
whoa hey I'm Brian Waddell this is my
brother Dean and you're watching film
courage so stay tuned